i was so scared for me it's just like
post office or authorities like a mafia
it's one of the biggest miscarriages of
justice in british history and its
appalling human consequences are still
being felt i was so much down and out at
one stage i was contemplating suicide
hundreds of innocent lives continue to
be tormented by what they went through
and by the lack of accountability the
stresses the feelings
the flashbacks the dreams the nightmares
[Music]
janet skinner had to learn to walk again
after a spinal infection paralyzed her
in 2008
she holds the post office responsible
certain it was stress induced
i can't walk
up these days
i had a day like that yesterday to be
honest but these days i just can't get
out of bed
i can't get up or i can't stand up i'm
amazes i've got like i've got this for
life the memories
that i've had
they're not just going to be erased you
know they'll never ever go away they
will always be there i've got a life
sentence for this
janet was one of those sent to prison
for a crime she didn't commit because of
a fault in her post office computer
she was convicted of false accounting at
her branch in hull at the time her
children were 17 and 14. during her
three months behind bars she didn't see
them
it was a memory i didn't want to have so
it was a memory that i knew i didn't
want them to have
i didn't speak to them i didn't write to
them
i was always there for both of them and
um
i never i never went anywhere and i
never did anything without them
but
i mean matthew didn't well agents okay
that easy easy either but tony took it
the hardest
how did it affect her
this is why we don't talk about it
because we just can't because we just
we just can't be open and talk openly
talk about it
right this year where the white board is
with the cash point
the branch where janet worked no longer
exists but the pain she associates with
it will never disappear
everybody knows everybody
chinese whispers and then obviously
because of what was
publicized i didn't want to come here so
you're worried about still being
recognised as and people thinking you're
guilty yeah
what's male items
more than 700 post office workers were
wrongly prosecuted in what became known
as the horizon i.t scandal
a fault in the post office accounting
software called horizon identified cash
shortfalls that didn't exist
thousands were hounded for money that
hadn't gone missing many went bankrupt
some went to prison and a few took their
own lives
[Music]
a statutory inquiry into the horizon
scandal was first called for more than
10 years ago it finally began here last
month and it aims to establish exactly
what went wrong how this happened
because despite the scale of the
suffering
no one has been held accountable
player and affirm declare and defer
tracy was just 19 when she went to
prison after being wrongly convicted of
theft
the whole truth and nothing but nothing
but the truth
i tried to kill myself
was that because you've been charged
with a criminal offence you hadn't
committed yes it was
i couldn't defend myself i couldn't
i couldn't explain
what had happened
20 years on the suicidal thoughts
continue
as does the intense therapy
it's made me the person i am today but
not the person that i want to be
um i don't want to be that girl that's
scared of noises that's scared to close
the door
or that has a breakdown sort of every
other month because something triggers
a reaction or triggers a memory that
causes my mental health to
to break down
[Music]
tracy's among 72 people who have had
their convictions quashed so far
but the elation is brief the trauma is
permanent
in her evidence tracy recounted how her
teenage son said he's glad he doesn't
share her surname so friends won't make
the connection
it killed me because i thought actually
my son believed that
it was better to not have the same
surname as me um
so yeah it totally ripped my heart out
the problems with horizon weren't
confined to one area they affected
branches all over the country and yet
throughout these hearings in london
cardiff and here in leeds witnesses have
said that when they called the post
office for help none was given and
instead they all say they were told
you're the only one having these issues
we wrote letters on a very frequent
basis for the area manager's office
belgiut sethi is among the thousands who
called the helpline in his case 135
times when shortfalls appeared at his
branch in brentwood
they didn't want to know they didn't
even come once to have a look
when they rose to 17 000 they said well
make this money good that means put in
the 17 000 and we will be terminating
your contract
that was in 2002 by then belgium and his
wife anjana had been running another
branch nearby for nearly 20 years
we did not let them take a single penny
we put our lives at risk they'd also
earned multiple certificates of bravery
for defending it against armed robberies
this stand for nothing now
the sethis were suspended and forced
into bankruptcy
only my wife and i knew it
oh we have struggled in this 20 years
we have worked so many hours
for a petty amount of money
despite his law degree the only job
bowjet could get was as a night time
security guard
i'm so bitter i'm so annoyed
that
why did this had to happen it would have
never happened so of course somebody
should take the brunt of it and be
punished for it this happened from top
to the bottom i'm not saying i was one
person responsible i blame everybody in
the post office
shunned by friends and former customers
has been another common theme in the
witness testimonies these are people
whose job made them central pillars of
their villages and their communities
only to be torn down to the point where
many
were afraid to go out
that's the farmhouse that i grew up in
tim brentnall took over the post office
in roach in pembrokeshire so he could
stay in the village where he grew up
after his conviction in 2010 it was
people he had known all his life who
were turning their backs
how did people hear react to your
conviction i was a fraudster i was a
thief i'd stolen
from from the old ladies in the village
people saying things to my face was
easier to handle than say walking into
the pub and you could hear whispers oh
there's the the guy that stolen the
money from the post office um when you
turn around and say sorry
oh no no no
we didn't just thought that's what made
me withdraw from from socials hides
[Music]
it's been a long time since it happened
and i don't think
i can't see how i can ever get back to
that
excited young man that i was
because they they also wanted to tim
still runs the village shop mainly
because no one will buy it
in ashford business has dwindled by 80
since his conviction
and he feels financially stuck
desperate to look to the future but
unable to escape the past and forced to
confront the post office on a daily
basis
sometimes it's really hard because some
people still might come in when i'm here
on the retail side
and expect me to be able to serve them
what do you say i have to say no i can't
i'm not allowed not allowed to do the
post office it's nothing to do with me
anymore how does that make you feel
that's horrific
it's just
it's a constant reminder of what
happened
those who had convictions overturned
have finally begun to be compensated
but no amount of money can make up for
what many went through
elder son kept dave alive and the
youngest one kept me alive
otherwise
we wouldn't be here
we wouldn't have been here the things we
have
gone through
sema mizrah was sent to prison on her
son's tenth birthday while eight weeks
pregnant with her second child oh my god
it was terrible uh
i never thought i'm gonna come out alive
from here
it was like you know if i would have
been pregnant i would have killed myself
that's for sure like it was like about
me for me was like i put a shame to my
family i was so worried about my baby's
health because
people were self-farming there
people were like on the drugs there i
thought like any anything is possible in
this country i thought somebody might
will come and just stab me
sema was released after four months so
gave birth to jairus outside prison but
then locked herself away for years
i haven't taken him to any play groups
or anything you know just we just stayed
in
for eight years bless him like we didn't
celebrate his birthday
because i didn't wanted
other his
his friends and fam their parents to
know that i'm
their mom i wasn't saying my full name
if somebody asked me what most my name
was man i never used to see my mister i
said what if they google it
to cover supposed shortfalls of 75 000
pounds the family was stripped of their
assets sema's husband devinder was
attacked in the street and became an
alcoholic
the sense of injustice
is still overwhelming
the way they crush our family the way
they crush our happiness the way they
crush our health our wealth our mind our
peace of mind they would lose the time
we're supposed to enjoy you know as a
young couple take all their money out
all their wealth out
and spread that wealth before you people
like us
that's called justice
in a statement the post office said it's
sincerely sorry for the impact of the
horizons scandal on the lives of victims
and their families and we are in no
doubt about the human cost
the inquiry's hearings enable many of
those who are most deeply affected by
post office's past failings to voice
their experiences and their testimonies
must and will ensure all lessons are
learned so that such events can never
happen again
the next phases of this inquiry will
focus on the horizon software which was
run by fujitsu and on who knew what
within the post office
former ceo paula vennels may be asked to
give evidence she ran the company
between 2012 and 2019 and was awarded a
cbe for her services to the post office
when contacted by sky news her legal
team declined to comment
but this first phase has been about the
victims
people are getting to listen to the real
life
stories
ignored for so long they're finally
being listened to i want them to sit
here
and feel what we feel
but there's still a long way to go for
them to get justice
iva bennett sky news
you